This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. So I'm talking with Katie Mangle, our senior producer. And you've been reporting for about a year and a half on homelessness here in the Bay area for a series that we're putting together right now. It's not ready. It's scheduled to come out at the end of the year. But since the coronavirus crisis has a huge impact on the unhoused population, we wanted
这里是《99%无形》。我是罗曼·马斯。我正在和我们的资深制作人凯蒂·曼格交谈。你已经在湾区报道无家可归者问题大约一年半了，这是我们目前正在制作的一个系列报道。它还没准备好，计划在年底发布。但由于新冠疫情对无家可归者群体产生了巨大影响，我们想
to check in. Yeah, so basically just as I was starting to wrap up the reporting process, the coronavirus came and it upended everything for everyone. And I've been struggling with how or whether to follow any of what's been happening in terms of COVID and homelessness. So not really knowing what I would do with any of it, I just started kind of checking in with people
了解一下情况。是的，基本上就在我刚要结束报道工作时，新冠病毒来了，它颠覆了所有人的生活。我一直在纠结如何处理，或者是否要跟进新冠疫情与无家可归者之间发生的任何事情。所以，在不知道该怎么做的情况下，我只是开始通过电话、Zoom之类的工具与人们联系，
just over, you know, the phone and zoom and whatnot, trying to at least kind of keep up with it all. And I was recording those conversations and I decided that some of them felt worth sharing. And it seems that homeless people are one of the populations that people are talking about as being particularly vulnerable to this disease. Yeah, so based on data that researchers already have about age and underlying health conditions in homeless people. A study from a team of researchers
试图至少跟上这一切。我录下了那些对话，并决定其中一些值得分享。似乎无家可归者是人们谈论的特别容易感染这种疾病的群体之一。是的，根据研究人员已经掌握的关于无家可归者年龄和潜在健康状况的数据。宾夕法尼亚大学和加州大学洛杉矶分校的一个研究团队进行的一项研究
at the University of Pennsylvania and UCLA found that homeless people would be twice as likely to be hospitalized as the general population, two to four times as likely to require critical care, and two to three times as likely to die if they contracted COVID-19. And it seems like some of the places where homeless people are the most visible, like the encampments and the shelters are really potential petri dishes for a disease like this to spread. Yeah, I mean social distancing is basically impossible in a shelter. And I think like all over the country, people are scrambling to prevent large scale outbreaks in homeless communities. I only know about what's happening in California. And yeah, I just
发现，如果感染了新冠病毒，无家可归者住院的可能性是普通人群的两倍，需要重症监护的可能性是普通人群的二到四倍，死亡的可能性是普通人群的二到三倍。而且，无家可归者最显眼的地方，比如营地和收容所，似乎确实是这种疾病传播的潜在培养皿。是的，我的意思是，在收容所里保持社交距离基本上是不可能的。而且我认为，全国各地的人们都在争先恐后地防止无家可归者社区出现大规模爆发。我只知道加州正在发生的事情。是的，我只是
wanted to share a few voices from that struggle, I guess we'll call it. The thing that is upside down about this is normally when there's a disaster, we work backwards. There's an earthquake, we work backwards. There's a flood, we work backwards. The thing happens and then we're getting ourselves out of it. This every day we go deeper in. I don't know where the bottom is. That's Jen Leving. She's the CEO of an organization called Destination Home that in regular times works on both ending and preventing homelessness in Santa Clara County. So in Clara County it's like it's San Jose and Palo Alto and Cooper, you know, it's basically when people say Silicon Valley, they mean Santa Clara County.
想分享一些来自那场斗争的声音，我想我们姑且称之为斗争吧。这件事最颠倒的地方在于，通常发生灾难时，我们是倒着工作的。发生地震，我们倒着工作。发生洪水，我们倒着工作。事情发生了，然后我们设法摆脱它。而这件事，我们每天都在陷得更深。我不知道底部在哪里。那是珍·莱文。她是“目的地家园”组织的首席执行官，该组织在正常时期致力于结束和预防圣克拉拉县的无家可归现象。所以，在克拉拉县，就像圣何塞、帕洛阿尔托和库珀，你知道，基本上当人们说硅谷时，他们指的就是圣克拉拉县。
Yeah. And Jen's agency destination home has been around since 2008. Um, but during this pandemic, it's, it's basically been kind of like conscripted into this chain of command, um, that's been activated at the county level through something called the Emergency Operations Center and every county in California has one of these. So the Emergency Operations Center or the EOC gets activated when there's an earthquake flood, some sort of things. This is the very first time though that and I've been a part of an activation a couple of times in my career. This is the first time though that and I've been a part of an activation a couple of times in my career.
是的。珍的机构“目的地家园”自2008年以来一直存在。嗯，但在这次大流行期间，它基本上就像是被征召进了这个指挥链，嗯，通过所谓的紧急行动中心在县一级被激活，加州的每个县都有一个这样的中心。所以，当发生地震、洪水或其他类似事情时，紧急行动中心或EOC就会被激活。不过，这是我职业生涯中第一次参与激活，而且我参与过几次激活。这是我职业生涯中第一次参与激活，而且我参与过几次激活。
This is the first time though that it was activated for a pandemic, which basically means that the Santa Clara County Public Health Department is in charge. If you're working in homelessness, you're not doing things on your own anymore, meaning supply chain, money, systems, everything gets deployed through this EOC. Yeah, so Jen is essentially working under the direction of the public health department on a few different things. And those things include opening up mass shelters so that existing shelters can be less crowded, bringing sanitation and medical care and resources
不过，这是第一次因为大流行而激活，这基本上意味着圣克拉拉县公共卫生部门负责。如果你在从事无家可归者工作，你就不能再独自行动了，这意味着供应链、资金、系统，一切都通过这个EOC进行部署。是的，所以珍基本上是在公共卫生部门的指导下处理几件不同的事情。这些事情包括开设大型收容所，以便现有的收容所可以不那么拥挤，为营地提供卫生设施、医疗护理和资源，
to encampments. And then also setting up partnerships with hotels where homeless people can potentially be quarantined. And then the last piece is trying to mitigate the financial catastrophe. If we can keep families from becoming homeless right now, there's a far better chance of recovery later. So we have to do, I think we have to do a few things and I think those things are happening.
以及与酒店建立合作关系，让无家可归者可以在那里进行隔离。最后一部分是试图减轻金融灾难。如果我们现在能让家庭不至于无家可归，那么以后恢复的机会就会大得多。所以我认为我们必须做几件事，而且我认为这些事情正在发生。
We have to have a vision more, Toria, and everywhere needs to have one. We need to make sure that there's food, free food accessible. I think this is also already happening, but like utilities, they need to stay on. Don't care, people don't pay, they have to stay on. And I believe that's also happening.
我们必须有一个愿景，托里亚，每个地方都需要有一个。我们需要确保有食物，免费的食物是可获得的。我认为这已经在发生了，但比如公用事业，它们需要保持运行。不管人们付不付钱，它们都必须保持运行。我相信这也正在发生。
When she says she believes that's happening, I just want to clarify that she means in her county. So that's obviously different wherever you live in the United States. The other really big thing Jen has been working on setting up is a fund. She raised $11 million very quickly to distribute to people who had lost employment and were at risk of becoming homeless. I mean, that seems like, I mean, that's a success. They raised a lot of money in the short amount of time. Is that enough? Yeah, I mean, I thought that sounded like a lot too, but it actually, it wasn't nearly enough.
当她说她相信这正在发生时，我只想澄清一下，她是说在她的县。所以这显然取决于你在美国的哪个地方。珍一直在努力建立的另一件非常重要的事情是一个基金。她很快筹集了1100万美元，用于分发给那些失去工作并面临无家可归风险的人。我的意思是，这看起来像，我的意思是，这是一个成功。他们在短时间内筹集了很多钱。这够吗？是的，我的意思是，我也觉得这听起来很多，但实际上，这远远不够。
Within three hours, we had 1,400 applications. They were coming in at two applications every minute. They crashed our server. And within three days, there were more than $11 million worth of qualifying applications. Yeah, you wrote in a tweet, I feel scared in a way that it's hard to describe. Ah, it's true. It's true, sister. And I'm not a chicken. I walk, I walk into the middle of the stuff for 20 years. And the scale is overwhelming people
在三个小时内，我们收到了1400份申请。申请以每分钟两份的速度涌入。它们弄垮了我们的服务器。在三天内，符合条件的申请金额就超过了1100万美元。是的，你在推特上写道，我感到一种难以形容的恐惧。啊，这是真的，这是真的，姐妹。我不是胆小鬼。我20年来一直深入这些事情的中心。这种规模让人不知所措，人们
already, already have no money left. Nothing. Jen estimates that they need about a hundred million dollars and that's again just in Santa Clara County to keep people housed during this time. And this is on top of the stimulus and unemployment checks and that's still not going to be enough. Yeah I mean for one those checks still haven't gotten to people for the most part. I think the first round of them is supposed to go out this week, but it sounds like it could be a while before everyone has their check. And then there are some people who won't be eligible for those benefits, undocumented
已经，已经没有钱了。什么都没有。珍估计他们需要大约一亿美元，这还是仅仅在圣克拉拉县，才能在这段时间内让人们有地方住。而且这还是在刺激计划和失业救济金之外的，即便如此还是不够。是的，我的意思是，首先，这些支票大部分还没有送到人们手中。我想第一轮支票应该在本周发出，但听起来可能还需要一段时间大家才能拿到支票。而且还有一些人没有资格获得这些福利，比如无证件
people, for example. And so have they been able to distribute the first 11 million that they gathered? Jen said some of it had started going out, but not all of it. I mean, it's a lot of work to process all of those applications and get all those checks out. And one of the problems they're running up against right now
的人。那么他们能够分发他们筹集到的前1100万美元了吗？珍说其中一部分已经开始发放了，但不是全部。我的意思是，处理所有这些申请并发出所有这些支票是一项繁重的工作。他们目前面临的问题之一
is that their volunteer support has dried up. And that's not just in their organization, that's happening in every organization. So if you think about most communities have a Meals on Wheels program, and what that is, is homebound people, vulnerable people, people who can't leave their home, there's meals that are prepared and delivered to them every day. Super cool,
是他们的志愿者支持已经枯竭了。这不仅仅是在他们的组织中，每个组织都在发生这种情况。所以如果你想想，大多数社区都有“送餐上门”项目，那是针对居家隔离的人、弱势群体、无法离开家的人，每天准备并送餐给他们。超级棒，
right? That is a 95% volunteer run situation. So when all volunteers disappear, all at once. Right? I think people are probably having trouble knowing how they should balance social distancing and volunteering. You know, that's a good question. So I will say that I think that's a personal choice. But what I will tell you is people that are already working on the front lines are in addition to that work, now delivering meals. Because here's the thing, it also has to be done. And COVID is asking us to do all of the things we were doing before and a thousand more things with less. And if you are able to be part of a solution, you need to get on being part of that solution.
对吧？那是一个95%由志愿者运营的情况。所以当所有志愿者同时消失时。对吧？我想人们可能很难知道他们应该如何平衡社交距离和志愿服务。你知道，这是一个好问题。所以我得说，我认为这是一个个人选择。但我会告诉你的是，已经在前线工作的人，除了那项工作之外，现在还在送餐。因为事情就是这样，它也必须完成。新冠疫情要求我们做我们以前做的所有事情，还要用更少的资源做一千件更多的事情。如果你能成为解决方案的一部分，你需要加入并成为解决方案的一部分。
And if that means money, or if that means so in a mask, or if that means you have to stay at home and not like complaining, you know, it means all those things. Because people who are the lowest paid workers in this nation who are largely people of color are out on the goddamn front lines. The last thing I wanted to ask Jen about in the, you know, 30 minutes I stole from her was, I don't know if you've been seeing these pictures of, like, homeless people being moved into, like, parking lots and stadiums.
如果这意味着钱，或者意味着缝制口罩，或者意味着你必须待在家里而不抱怨，你知道，这意味着所有这些事情。因为这个国家薪水最低的工人，他们大多是有色人种，正站在该死的火线上。在从珍那里偷来的30分钟里，我想问她的最后一件事是，我不知道你是否看到了这些照片，比如无家可归者被转移到停车场和体育场。
Yeah, there was a picture from Las Vegas where they had a grid was painted out to mark, you know, like, how far they should be camping, like, away from each other. Otherwise, it was just like, it was just like, it was an open parking lot. There was no covering. There was no real shelter. It just was designated spaces on the ground. Yes.
是的，有一张来自拉斯维加斯的照片，他们画了一个网格来标记，你知道，比如，他们应该离彼此多远露营。否则，它就像，它就像，它只是一个露天停车场。没有遮盖。没有真正的住所。它只是地面上指定的空间。是的。
Yeah. Which they did because a resident in a, like, a 500 bed shelter had tested positive for COVID. And so they needed to get everyone out of that space to prevent the virus from spreading. So they moved people into this open, air parking lot. I think they've since been moved back inside. But I just wondered kind of what she thought of that or things like that.
是的。他们这样做是因为一个500张床位的收容所里的一名居民新冠检测呈阳性。所以他们需要把每个人都从那个空间里弄出来，以防止病毒传播。所以他们把人们转移到了这个露天停车场。我想他们后来又被搬回了室内。但我只是想知道她对那个或类似的事情有什么看法。
I guess I wonder from your perspective when you see something like that, are you kind of like, yep, it's a crazy time. People are coming up with crazy solutions. Or does that strike you as like, we should be able to do way better than that. You know, I think now, look, pre-COVID-America has treated homelessness in every kind of reprehensible way. Right now though, the people that are trying to do
我想从你的角度来看，当你看到这样的事情时，你是觉得，是的，这是一个疯狂的时代。人们正在想出疯狂的解决方案。还是这让你觉得，我们应该能做得比那好得多。你知道，我认为现在，看，新冠疫情前的美国以各种应受谴责的方式对待无家可归者。不过现在，那些试图做
the things that you're describing, I'm not criticizing them because this is hell. If that's the best that they can do, then that must be the best they can do. We are not doing that. Right? But I am in no positions that criticize other communities because you know, we're not. We don't have every homeless person in this stable place. We're sheltering it in campus.
你所描述的事情的人，我并没有批评他们，因为这是地狱。如果那是他们能做的最好的事情，那么那一定就是他们能做的最好的事情。我们没有那样做。对吧？但我没有立场去批评其他社区，因为你知道，我们没有。我们没有让每个无家可归者都处于稳定的地方。我们在营地提供住所。
That is totally wrong. You know what I mean, but we can't. We have asked America to give us more places for homeless people for, you know, my whole career. Now they're telling us all to do it in a week. It's amazing. You know? Well, thank you so much for your time. Yeah, I got to go, I got to go, sister, but yeah, check in with me and whatever you feel like you're curious about something. Yeah, and best of luck out there. Hey, thanks so much.
那是完全错误的。你知道我的意思，但我们不能。我们要求美国为无家可归者提供更多地方，你知道，在我整个职业生涯中。现在他们告诉我们所有人要在这一周内完成。这太神奇了。你知道吗？好吧，非常感谢你的时间。是的，我得走了，我得走了，姐妹，但是的，随时联系我，无论你对什么感到好奇。是的，祝你好运。嘿，非常感谢。
One of the things you said Jen was trying to do was securing hotel rooms for homeless people. Is that part of the governor's program? Yeah, so on April 3rd, Governor Newsom announced something that he called Project Room Key. He said he had secured almost 7,000 hotel rooms for homeless people, and that they were on their way to getting 15,000. It's a county state partnership with the county fundamentally driving the car
你提到的珍试图做的事情之一是为无家可归者争取酒店房间。那是州长计划的一部分吗？是的，4月3日，纽森州长宣布了一项他称之为“房间钥匙计划”的项目。他说他已经为无家可归者争取到了近7000个酒店房间，而且他们正在争取达到15000个。这是一个县与州的伙伴关系，县从根本上在驾驶这辆车，
and the state of California building the car. We put together the technical teams and expertise. We are working with the counties as they identify these sites to get the operating agreements up and running. So yeah, when he says that counties are driving the car, he means these emergency operation centers and people like Jen who are out there, you know,
而加利福尼亚州在制造这辆车。我们组建了技术团队和专家组。我们正在与各县合作，当他们确定这些地点时，我们会启动运营协议。所以是的，当他说各县在驾驶这辆车时，他指的是这些紧急行动中心，以及像珍这样在外面的人，你知道，
making calls to hotel owners to get them to agree to rent rooms to the state. And he's talking about 15,000 rooms across the entire state. And then again, sounds like it's a lot, but I know for a fact that that's not enough. Yeah, exactly because they're at least 150,000 homeless people in California, which is why in some places, you have activists calling on mayors to do more. So on April 3rd, actually, the same day is that NUSOM press conference. There was a protest in San Francisco. It was a car protest, which is one of the amazing new things that we have in this new pandemic era, where a bunch of people drove their cars to this convention center in San Francisco, where
给酒店老板打电话，让他们同意把房间租给州政府。他谈论的是整个州15000个房间。然后再次，听起来很多，但我确实知道这还不够。是的，完全正确，因为加州至少有15万无家可归者，这就是为什么在某些地方，你有活动人士呼吁市长们做得更多。所以4月3日，实际上就是纽森新闻发布会的那一天。旧金山发生了一场抗议。这是一场汽车抗议，这是我们在新的大流行时代拥有的令人惊奇的新事物之一，一群人开车到旧金山的这个会议中心，那里
the city was planning on housing homeless people, sort of on the floor on mats. And the people in cars, you know, sat outside of this convention center honking in protest. They thought that people shouldn't be sheltered together in this big open area, but instead put into hotel rooms. And they were urging the mayor to use her power to get hotel rooms for people. A killer van of cars circled San Francisco's Moscone Center, while Mayor London breed and city officials held a virtual press conference inside. The message is still loud and clear at the socially distant protest.
城市计划安置无家可归者，某种程度上是睡在地板上的垫子上。车里的人，你知道，坐在会议中心外鸣笛抗议。他们认为人们不应该被安置在这个大的开放区域，而应该被安置在酒店房间里。他们敦促市长利用她的权力为人们争取酒店房间。一辆载满汽车的货车绕着旧金山的莫斯康中心行驶，而伦敦·布里德市长和市政府官员在里面举行虚拟新闻发布会。在保持社交距离的抗议活动中，信息依然响亮而清晰。
I talked to this sociologist named Chris Herring who was part of that protest movement to get more hotel rooms. And he says the mayor, London breed, has the authority to commandeer hotel rooms in an emergency. So if they have the power to do it, why aren't they doing it? I mean, it's a power that they don't use very often. Yeah. You know, they say that it's too expensive to put every single homeless person in a hotel. They also say that it's much more complicated than you might think to move people into hotels. You have to have all
我和一位名叫克里斯·赫林的社会学家谈过，他是那个争取更多酒店房间的抗议运动的一部分。他说，伦敦·布里德市长有权在紧急情况下征用酒店房间。所以如果他们有权力这样做，为什么他们不这样做呢？我的意思是，这是一种他们不经常使用的权力。是的。你知道，他们说把每个无家可归者都安置在酒店里太贵了。他们还说，把人们搬进酒店比你想象的要复杂得多。你必须拥有所有
this supportive staff who will provide food and services and clean the rooms and you can't just like move people in and that's it it. Yeah, totally. But after that protest, the city did decide not to use the convention center as a mass shelter. And Mayor Reed said she's negotiating to bring 7,000 more hotel rooms into use specifically for homeless people in San Francisco. And so in terms of the hotel rooms that do exist either in San Francisco or more generally across the state, who is getting into those? Well, so not nearly all of those hotels have been filled yet. It's hard to get numbers on this, but some sources are saying that something close to 2,000 rooms across the state have been filled. I think most of the focus so far has been on shelters.
这些支持人员，他们将提供食物和服务，清洁房间，你不能只是把人搬进去就完事了。是的，完全正确。但在那次抗议之后，市政府确实决定不使用会议中心作为大型收容所。布里德市长说她正在谈判，为旧金山的无家可归者专门提供7000个酒店房间。那么，就旧金山或整个州现有的酒店房间而言，谁能住进去呢？嗯，所以并不是所有的酒店都住满了。很难得到这方面的数字，但一些消息来源称，全州有接近2000个房间已经住满了。我认为到目前为止，大部分重点都放在了收容所上。
So if there's a shelter where there's a positive case, they're putting people from that shelter who they think may have been exposed into hotels. Part of the criticism right now from advocates is that it's sort of a reactive approach instead of a proactive one, meaning that instead of just immediately putting all homeless people into hotels, they're waiting for cases to break out in shelters. And it's also very much a referral-based system. So if you think you have COVID, you still have to be referred to a hotel room by an approved medical or outreach worker. It's almost like getting a prescription for a hotel room. Last Friday, the 10th of April, mayor breed announced that there had been a major outbreak of coronavirus in a shelter in San Francisco. The last numbers I saw were that 92 residents and 10 workers had tested positive, but those
所以如果有一个收容所出现了阳性病例，他们会把他们认为可能接触过该收容所的人转移到酒店。目前倡导者批评的一部分是，这是一种反应式的方法，而不是主动式的方法，这意味着他们不是立即把所有无家可归者安置在酒店，而是在等待病例在收容所爆发。而且这在很大程度上是一个基于转诊的系统。所以如果你认为你感染了新冠，你仍然必须由批准的医疗或外展工作者转诊到酒店房间。这几乎就像是获得酒店房间的处方。上周五，4月10日，布里德市长宣布旧金山的一个收容所爆发了大规模的新冠疫情。我看到的最后数字是92名居民和10名工作人员检测呈阳性，但这些
numbers will probably keep going up. In any case, according to the New York Times, it's the biggest outbreak in a shelter so far in the US. So right now, some of the people in shelters are going into hotels, but only if they've been exposed to the virus. But that doesn't account for all the people in the encampments. What are they doing? Yeah, I mean, I was wondering about this, like how much outreach is happening in encampments,
数字可能会继续上升。无论如何，据《纽约时报》报道，这是美国迄今为止收容所中规模最大的一次爆发。所以现在，收容所里的一些人正在进入酒店，但前提是他们接触过病毒。但这并不能解释营地里的所有人。他们在做什么？是的，我的意思是，我一直在想这个问题，比如营地里有多少外展工作正在进行，
where people checking, are people checking on folks outside or testing folks outside? I haven't been going into the field much lately for the same reasons that we're all staying home, but I decided I wanted to try and talk to a few people and an encampment, so I put on gloves and a mask and I went out to a camp in Berkeley where I've spent a good bit of time.
人们在检查吗，人们在检查外面的人还是在外面测试人们？出于我们大家都待在家里的同样原因，我最近没有怎么去实地考察，但我决定我想尝试和营地里的几个人谈谈，所以我戴上手套和口罩，去了伯克利的一个营地，我在那里花了不少时间。
So that's Shauna sitting outside of her tent with her friend Jade. So that's Shauna sitting outside of her tent with her friend Jade. Shauna lives in a camp and with about 60 other people, mostly intense. And they said that a nurse practitioner and a social worker had just been out to the camp. And when were they here? Just probably 20 minutes. Maybe 20, 30 minutes ago. And were they just kind of checking to see if anybody had been sick or anything? Yeah, they've been coming out a couple of times and we come check up on everyone out here.
所以那是肖娜和她的朋友杰德坐在帐篷外面。所以那是肖娜和她的朋友杰德坐在帐篷外面。肖娜住在一个大约有60人的营地里，大多住在帐篷里。他们说一名执业护士和社会工作者刚刚来过营地。他们是什么时候来的？大概20分钟前。也许20、30分钟前。他们只是在检查有没有人生病之类的吗？是的，他们来过几次，我们来检查这里的所有人。
Sean has said that one guy from the encampment had shown symptoms of COVID-19 and one of the outreach workers made sure he got tested and into a hotel. But it seemed like that was the only person so far that had gone to a hotel out there. And do you guys feel like you're doing any extra like hand washing or... I've done hand washing. Bit more, yeah. A little bit more. And using the hand sanitizer more.
肖娜说，营地里有一个人出现了新冠肺炎症状，其中一名外展工作者确保他接受了检测并住进了酒店。但看起来那是到目前为止唯一一个住进酒店的人。你们觉得你们在做任何额外的洗手之类的吗……我洗手了。多了一点，是的。多了一点。而且更多地使用洗手液。
At least trying to keep the hands a little bit. I've been washing up in a bucket. Like, I don't care. Like, I gotta stamp all night, hygiene somehow. And how nervous does everyone there seem to be about all this? Yeah, I was wondering that. I asked that too. Do you feel like you're stressed out about the virus? Shona?
至少试图保持手部稍微干净一点。我一直在用桶洗手。就像，我不在乎。就像，我必须整晚保持卫生，以某种方式。大家对这一切感到多紧张？是的，我也在想这个问题。我也问过那个问题。你觉得你对病毒感到压力吗？肖娜？
Not so much about the virus, just life in general. There's other things to be stressed about. What do you feel like is the main thing you're stressed about right now? Being poor and not being mentally able to work all the time and being stable. I relapsed. I was a year and a half clean and I relapsed. So I don't feel bad out at relapsed after 14 years. So I feel like a failure right now. And then all this other stuff's going on.
不是对病毒那么紧张，只是对生活本身。还有其他事情要担心。你觉得你现在最大的压力是什么？贫穷，没有精神能力一直工作，而且不稳定。我复吸了。我戒了有一年半了，但我复吸了。所以我对自己14年后复吸感到不好。所以我现在觉得自己是个失败者。然后所有这些其他事情都在发生。
So it's just like, it's hard to focus on that when I relax. So. This camp actually has sort of relative to other camps, a good bit of outreach. There's a couple clinics who send workers there. And they have this one extremely dedicated activist named Andrea Henson, who's out there almost every day. and workers there. And they have this one extremely dedicated activist named
所以，当我复吸时，很难专注于那个。所以。这个营地实际上相对于其他营地，有相当多的外展服务。有几家诊所派工作人员到那里。他们有一位非常敬业的活动家，名叫安德里亚·亨森，她几乎每天都在那里。工作人员在那里。他们有一位非常敬业的活动家，名叫
Andrea Henson, who's out there almost every day. Andrea's been raising money through a go-fun me and handing out things like hand sanitizer and face masks. Where are they, ball-cloth, ball-a-cabas? Ball-a-cabas? Yeah, I call them a baklava, it's a bitch. A lot of the ways that homeless people make money are not possible right now.
安德里亚·亨森，她几乎每天都在那里。安德里亚一直在通过GoFundMe筹集资金，并分发洗手液和口罩之类的东西。它们在哪里，巴拉克拉瓦帽？巴拉克拉瓦帽？是的，我叫它们巴拉克拉瓦帽，真麻烦。无家可归者赚钱的很多方式现在都不可能了。
People used to collect cans to sell it recycling centers, and those centers are mostly closed. Panhandling is more difficult right now. So lately, Andrea has had to bring food to the encampment. I never had to provide food before, and I just chanted out, I mean, we prepped 300 beds of grocery. I'm not a food distribution person,
人们过去常收集罐子卖给回收中心，而那些中心大多关闭了。现在乞讨更困难了。所以最近，安德里亚不得不给营地带食物。我以前从不需要提供食物，我只是分发，我的意思是，我们准备了300袋杂货。我不是一个食品分发人员，
but I had to be because people were telling me they're hungry. She also recently rented a bobcat to try to get all the trash out of the encampment, and she's been paying some of the people around there to help. Again, just all through a go-fun me. We have to get this trash picked up because in order to mitigate this health crisis in the camp,
但我必须是，因为人们告诉我他们饿了。她最近还租了一辆滑移装载机，试图把营地里的所有垃圾清理干净，她一直在付钱给周围的一些人帮忙。同样，都是通过GoFundMe。我们必须把这些垃圾清理掉，因为为了减轻营地的这场健康危机，
you know, I'm buying it to be tense for people, but we're putting them in filthy places. We're instilling porta-podies in filthy places. Yeah, so a lot of dedicated people out there working really, really hard right now, but, you know, like Jen said, there are thousands of homeless people in California, and now, you know, everyone wants this all to be solved like yesterday. So, it's tough. What do you think we can do? I was like, please, if you wanted to, any word to get it done, whenever you're ready, then I'll pay you.
你知道，我正在买帐篷给人们，但我们把他们放在肮脏的地方。我们在肮脏的地方安装移动厕所。是的，所以有很多敬业的人在那里非常非常努力地工作，但是，你知道，就像珍说的，加州有成千上万的无家可归者，现在，你知道，每个人都希望这一切像昨天一样被解决。所以，这很难。你觉得我们能做什么？我说，拜托，如果你愿意，任何能完成它的词，只要你准备好了，我就付钱给你。
I have the garbage bag. I have, we'll put it all the trash on the corner. Go take a take. Bye, Grant. Yeah. Okay, when you're ready, we're gonna move on on to the first time I'll put you on a job program. And I'm going to take you for minimum wage. You can do it once, so I'll give you.
我有垃圾袋。我有，我们会把所有的垃圾放在角落里。去拿一个拿一个。再见，格兰特。是的。好的，当你准备好了，我们要进入第一次，我会把你安排在一个工作计划中。我会给你最低工资。你可以做一次，所以我给你。
They have a wage. You just tell me what time you start. We're going to move for you to go for everything you've done. Our Unhoused series will be out at the end of the year. If you want to find out more about any of the people or organizations we mentioned in this episode or how you can help or get involved, go to our website at sni9py.org. We'll do the research for this episode, Katie's assistant producer Abby Medon ran across a historian who studied the role that hotels have played in times of crisis. Katie Mingle will be back to talk about that after this.
他们有工资。你只要告诉我你什么时候开始。我们要为你所做的一切而行动。我们的“无家可归者”系列将在年底发布。如果你想了解更多关于我们在本集提到的任何人或组织，或者你如何提供帮助或参与，请访问我们的网站sni9py.org。我们将为这一集做研究，凯蒂的助理制作人艾比·梅登遇到了一位研究酒店在危机时期所扮演角色的历史学家。凯蒂·明格将在之后回来谈论这个。
From her apartment in Oakland, here again, is Katie Mingle. St. Francisco and other cities are looking to repurpose vacant hotels to shelter unhoused people during this coronavirus outbreak. But this isn't the first time hotels have been used as crucial infrastructure in times of crisis. I wanted to find out more about the history of people repurposing hotels this way. So I called up Kenneth Morrison. Hello, my name is Kenneth Morrison, and I'm a professor of modern European history, and I'm based at Demoteford University in Leicester
从她在奥克兰的公寓里，再次欢迎凯蒂·明格。旧金山和其他城市正在寻求重新利用空置酒店，以便在这次新冠疫情期间安置无家可归者。但这并不是酒店第一次在危机时期被用作关键基础设施。我想更多地了解人们以这种方式重新利用酒店的历史。所以我打电话给了肯尼斯·莫里森。你好，我叫肯尼斯·莫里森，我是现代欧洲历史教授，我在英国莱斯特的德蒙福特大学工作。
in the United Kingdom. And so why is it that hotels in particular are deployed in this kind of way? Like what is it about a hotel that makes it very useful in a moment like this? I mean hotels and many respects are perfect for being repurposed in the way that they are right now. So if you think about the microstructure of a hotel, you have large kitchens, you know, lots of refrigeration, you have supply chains. So basically, the hotel can continue to function. It might not be serving the same food, or it might not be serving the same drinks, or whatever, but it can continue to function.
那么为什么酒店特别以这种方式被部署呢？比如酒店有什么特点使它在这样的时刻非常有用？我的意思是，酒店在许多方面非常适合以目前的方式被重新利用。所以如果你想想酒店的微观结构，你有大型厨房，你知道，大量的冷藏设备，你有供应链。所以基本上，酒店可以继续运作。它可能不提供同样的食物，或者它可能不提供同样的饮料，或者其他什么，但它可以继续运作。
It works. And if you think about the internal structure of a hotel, most hotels have a quite large atrium, so, you know, atrium can be used as places where medical personnel are perhaps based or seeing people as they come in. And all of the rooms function as these kind of isolation units, because when people go and stay in hotels, you know, perhaps they've just got married or there, you know, couples going away for a weekend without the children or whatever, there's, you know, a certain amount of privacy required. So of course that means that every room has to be kind of insulated and isolated. And in the context of the COVID-19 crisis, it's perfect because you have these huge corridors
它有效。如果你想想酒店的内部结构，大多数酒店都有一个相当大的中庭，所以，你知道，中庭可以用作医疗人员可能驻扎的地方，或者在人们进来时看他们的地方。所有的房间都作为这种隔离单元运作，因为当人们去住酒店时，你知道，也许他们刚结婚，或者他们是，你知道，夫妻俩周末出去玩而不带孩子，或者其他什么，你知道，需要一定程度的隐私。所以当然这意味着每个房间都必须被某种程度上隔绝和隔离。在新冠疫情的背景下，这很完美，因为你有这些巨大的走廊，
where food can be left outside the door and the person can be left within this kind of isolated unit which is the room. And the room of course always has on-sweep facilities so they can shower in the room, they can wash, they can sleep, they can watch television, they have access to the internet. So being used as a quarantine centre hotels do that particularly effectively. And if we think of other buildings that might be used as quarantine centers, sports halls, for example, those sports halls have to be internally reconstructed in order to become quarantine centers or field hospitals. Actually, you have to do a lot less of that in a hotel. So hotel functions really well. If you repurpose very, very quickly.
食物可以放在门外，人可以留在这个作为房间的隔离单元内。而且房间当然总是有套房设施，所以他们可以在房间里淋浴，他们可以洗澡，他们可以睡觉，他们可以看电视，他们可以上网。所以作为隔离中心使用，酒店做得特别有效。如果我们想到可能被用作隔离中心的其他建筑，例如体育馆，那些体育馆必须在内部进行改造才能成为隔离中心或野战医院。实际上，你在酒店里需要做的改造要少得多。所以酒店运作得非常好。如果你重新利用得非常非常快。
Can you talk a little bit about how hotels were repurposed during the recent European refugee crisis? Yes, I mean, in the case of the migrant stroke refugee crisis in 2015, 2016, of course, you had millions of people coming to the European continent, and sometimes they had to be hailed in camps, but other times they would be held in hotels, so they would be kept in hotels. And there are various different examples of this. The biggest example of this is what happened in Germany, because of course the vast majority of those migrants that were seeking to lead places like Libya and Syria in 2015,
你能谈谈在最近的欧洲难民危机期间酒店是如何被重新利用的吗？是的，我的意思是，在2015年、2016年的移民/难民危机中，当然，有数百万人来到欧洲大陆，有时他们必须被安置在营地，但其他时候他们会被安置在酒店，所以他们会被留在酒店。这有各种不同的例子。这方面最大的例子是德国发生的事情，因为当然，2015年、
2016, were heading for Germany. And when Angela Merkel essentially said that refugees, migrants are welcome, she was then faced with a problem, what do we do with this sheer number of people? We have to house them somewhere. And the German government actually entered into a number of contracts, agreements with large hotel groups so that the refugees would be housed there.
2016年那些试图离开利比亚和叙利亚等地方的绝大多数移民都在前往德国。当安格拉·默克尔基本上说难民、移民受欢迎时，她随后面临一个问题，我们该拿这些数量庞大的人怎么办？我们必须把他们安置在某个地方。德国政府实际上与大型酒店集团签订了一些合同、协议，以便难民可以安置在那里。
And they would be housed there for a short time until they could be genuinely incorporated into society. If you get jobs, they could then perhaps slip for apartments of their own and so forth. But the hotel in that context played a really important role in managing that immediate crisis. And that, given the sheer numbers of people that arrived in Germany at that time, has actually been a relative success story, but it wouldn't have been possible without the hotels and the role that the hotel played in that huge movement of people. And were the hotels still kind of like hotels or were they more like apartments where there
他们会被安置在那里一小段时间，直到他们能真正融入社会。如果他们找到工作，他们就可以搬进自己的公寓等等。但在那种背景下，酒店在管理那场即时危机中发挥了非常重要的作用。而且，考虑到当时到达德国的人数之多，这实际上是一个相对成功的案例，但如果没有酒店以及酒店在那场巨大的人口流动中所发挥的作用，这是不可能实现的。那么酒店当时还是像酒店一样，还是更像公寓，没有
wasn't necessarily a counter where you check in and how was it different when the refugees were housed in these places? So basically there were two types of hotels. There were the ones that were completely taken over, essentially. Government contract, German government paid grand city hotels for the use of these 22 hotels in Berlin, for example. And what it meant was that the German government were giving to the hotel industry the finance for that, so that they could continue to operate. So the hotel, for them, at guaranteed,
一定有办理入住的柜台，当难民被安置在这些地方时，有什么不同？所以基本上有两种类型的酒店。有些是基本上被完全接管的。政府合同，德国政府为使用这些酒店支付费用，例如柏林有22家酒店。这意味着德国政府正在向酒店业提供资金，以便他们能够继续运营。所以酒店对他们来说，保证了，
more or less 100% occupancy rates, but they weren't really functioning as hotels at that time. They weren't serving breakfast at lunch and dinner. At many of the staff that worked, they continued to work there. They were cleaning, they were making food for the refugees and so forth, but it wasn't functioning as a normal hotel.
或多或少100%的入住率，但它们当时并没有真正作为酒店运作。它们没有提供早餐、午餐和晚餐。许多在那里工作的工作人员继续在那里工作。他们在清洁，他们在为难民做饭等等，但它并没有作为一家正常的酒店运作。
However, there were other hotels that were actually allowing refugees to work there and training them, and giving them skills that would make it possible for them to enter into work within German society. This happened in Germany, it happened in Austria, it happened in Belgium. Refugees were given an opportunity to train as barmen, to train as waiters, doing silver service and so forth. So they needed to train and do something that would allow them to make a living very, very quickly. And again, the hotel place is this very important rule.
然而，还有其他酒店实际上允许难民在那里工作并培训他们，并赋予他们技能，使他们有可能进入德国社会工作。这发生在德国，发生在奥地利，发生在比利时。难民有机会接受培训成为酒保，接受培训成为服务员，做银器服务等等。所以他们需要接受培训并做一些事情，让他们能够非常非常快地谋生。同样，酒店在这个非常重要的规则中占据了一席之地。
And did you hear stories about what these places were like? It strikes me as potentially hard to suddenly turn a hotel into this very different function. Did you hear stories of what it was like? How did they feed people? How did it work? The difficulty with redeploying a hotel like that, and it was much less the case in Germany, but in other places, locals were very suspicious of a large hotel being taken
你听说过这些地方是什么样的故事吗？这让我觉得突然把一家酒店变成这种非常不同的功能可能很困难。你听说过它是什么样的故事吗？他们如何喂养人们？它是如何运作的？重新部署像那样的酒店的困难在于，在德国这种情况要少得多，但在其他地方，当地人对一家大型酒店被接管
over and used as a place to house refugees. So in Ireland, the Republic of Ireland, for example, you had a number of hotels that were redeployed in this way. And lots of luxury hotels were built in Ireland prior to the economic crash of 2008. And of course, after 2008, there wasn't a market. There simply wasn't a market for them. So the hoteliers had to find a way to use the space that they had. So many of these hotels were used as places to house refugees.
并用作安置难民的地方非常怀疑。所以在爱尔兰，例如爱尔兰共和国，你有一些酒店以这种方式被重新部署。在2008年经济崩溃之前，爱尔兰建造了许多豪华酒店。当然，2008年之后，没有市场。根本没有市场。所以酒店经营者必须找到一种方法来利用他们拥有的空间。所以许多这些酒店被用作安置难民的地方。
Now, sometimes there was a lot of suspicion coming from local populations who weren't happy about this. They felt that putting refugees in a hotel was not an effective way to bring them into the society. You were basically isolating them from society, and it created this kind of ascent them feeling. But these were only ever intended to be temporary spaces, three months, six months, and then they would be, it was part of a kind of wider redistribution program where the refugees wouldn't stay in the hotel for too long. They would be moved on quite quickly. But within the hotels themselves, no, they weren't functioning as ordinary hotels, but there was catering there because that was part of the agreement with the governments that there would be catering for the new guests. But it wouldn't have been anything alike,
现在，有时当地居民会有很多怀疑，他们对这一点不高兴。他们觉得把难民安置在酒店不是让他们融入社会的有效方式。你基本上是在把他们与社会隔离开来，这创造了这种“他们与我们”的感觉。但这只是打算作为临时空间，三个月，六个月，然后他们会被，这是某种更广泛的重新分配计划的一部分，难民不会在酒店待太久。他们会被很快转移走。但在酒店内部，不，它们没有作为普通酒店运作，但那里有餐饮，因为那是与政府协议的一部分，即为新客人提供餐饮。但这绝不会像，
the kind of service that a normal hotel would provide in normal times. Right. And then did some of those hotels go back to being sort of normal tourist hotels after? They did. Because of course once the economic situation began to improve in Europe. After 2008, you had the Euro crisis by 2014, you have the beginning of this refugee crisis. But really by 2016, the European economies are a bit more stable. And many of these hotels go back to being exactly what they were intended to be. And is there anything about that process
正常酒店在正常时期提供的服务。对。那么其中一些酒店在之后又变回了普通的旅游酒店吗？是的。因为当然，一旦欧洲的经济状况开始好转。2008年之后，你有欧元危机，到2014年，你有这场难民危机的开始。但实际上到2016年，欧洲经济稍微稳定了一些。许多这些酒店又变回了它们原本打算成为的样子。那么关于那个过程有什么
of converting back that was interesting? Like they probably have to kind of clean and re maybe refurbish some of the rooms? I don't know, like is there a process? Yes, but it's actually a big, extremely business-like. And this is what's so interesting about the transitions that these buildings go through, yes, of course, there will have been the need to redecorate and probably. That was part of the contract with the German government, for example, there was a slice of money in there for that redecoration to take place at the end, because they knew that obviously it wouldn't be. Perhaps kept in the same way as it would have been when functioning as a normal hotel.
转换回来的有趣之处吗？比如他们可能必须清理并重新装修一些房间？我不知道，比如有一个过程吗？是的，但这实际上是非常商业化的。这就是这些建筑所经历的转变如此有趣的地方，是的，当然，会有重新装修的需要，可能。例如，这是与德国政府合同的一部分，最后有一笔钱用于进行那种重新装修，因为他们知道显然它不会。也许保持得像它作为正常酒店运作时那样。
But they just moved back to being the spaces that they were and used for the purpose that they were intended for. These are business arrangements, in essence, what we've seen in the case of the refugee crisis in Europe. The building is needed for a specific period of time. VADES hotels are offered, the German government sign, or German Dutch Belgian government sign, agreement to rent a hotel for that purpose. And then there's the, as I mentioned, the slice of money that's given to to redecorate or convert the hotel afterwards back to being a normal hotel.
但它们只是变回了它们原本的空间，并用于它们原本打算的用途。这些本质上是商业安排，我们在欧洲难民危机中看到的就是这样。建筑在特定时期内是需要的。酒店被提供，德国政府签署，或者德国、荷兰、比利时政府签署协议租用酒店用于该目的。然后正如我提到的，有一笔钱用于重新装修或之后将酒店转换回正常的酒店。
There are some activists here in the Bay Area like San Francisco, Oakland, who are, you know, the governor here in California has already announced a plan to bring about 15,000 hotel rooms sort of into to being used to to house homeless people here. We have a lot of homeless people in California, but there are activists that are calling on like the mayor of San Francisco, for example, to do to kind of like go a step further and instead of carefully negotiating these deals with hotels to actually like, commandeer them, and that's not a step that she is going to take. It doesn't seem, but have you heard of things like that happening where like people use kind of like an executive privilege to take over hotels when they need to?
在旧金山、奥克兰等湾区，有一些活动人士，你知道，加州州长已经宣布了一项计划，将大约15000间酒店客房用于安置无家可归者。加州有很多无家可归者，但有一些活动人士呼吁，比如旧金山市长，更进一步，不要与酒店进行谨慎的谈判，而是直接征用它们。但这似乎不是她会采取的步骤。你听说过类似的事情吗，比如人们利用行政特权在需要时接管酒店？
Yes, and they can be commandeered in times of crisis. Buildings like hotels can often be strategic assets, because they often occupy strategic heights. They can be quite tall buildings, and particularly in an urban conflict, control of the strategic heights is extremely important. So, you know, sometimes hotels can be common-deared for that purpose. What we're facing now with the COVID-19 crisis is something really unique
是的，在危机时期它们是可以被征用的。像酒店这样的建筑通常是战略资产，因为它们往往占据战略高地。它们可能是相当高的建筑，特别是在城市冲突中，控制战略高地极其重要。所以，你知道，有时酒店可以为此目的被征用。我们现在面临的新冠疫情危机是非常独特的。
and in the context of the United States, for example, that to think that any politician could tell business or a hotel owner that they simply have to take the hotel and commandeer it for that purpose is hugely controversial. We've never been, I think, in a situation in Europe of the United States where that has been necessary, certainly not in living memory. It was necessary during the Second World War where lots of hotels were commandeered, either as field hospitals or bases for various agencies, government agencies who had to move out. London, during the blitz, for example, they had to take over these buildings and turn them into something else for a temporary period until the war was over.
以美国为例，认为任何政客都可以告诉企业或酒店老板，他们必须交出酒店并将其征用，这是极具争议的。我认为在欧洲或美国，我们从未处于需要这样做的境地，至少在有生之年没有。这在第二次世界大战期间是必要的，当时许多酒店被征用，要么作为野战医院，要么作为各种政府机构的基地，因为他们不得不搬迁。例如，在伦敦大轰炸期间，他们不得不接管这些建筑，并在战争结束前将其临时改作他用。
So it's not without precedent, but normally happens under the emergency powers that are enacted in the context of conflict. Well, maybe you could talk a little bit about what you're seeing in terms of the COVID-19 crisis, like what kind of role you're seeing hotels start to take. Absolutely. And New York, I mean, you had a couple of really nice hotels, they sent Regis the Plaza, you hotel, yeah, they become temporary fields hospitals, but for non-critical patients.
所以这并非没有先例，但通常是在冲突背景下颁布的紧急权力下发生的。也许你可以谈谈你在新冠疫情危机中看到的情况，比如你看到酒店开始扮演什么样的角色。当然。在纽约，有一些非常好的酒店，比如瑞吉酒店、广场酒店，它们变成了临时野战医院，但只针对非危重病人。
So it's to basically take the pressure of the hospitals themselves. And then of course the four seasons in Manhattan, which in any ordinary time would be a rather expensive place to live is now being opened up to healthcare workers. I mean, who tells now are being used in a number of ways. So they're being used primarily as quarantine centers because of course so many people have had to leave
所以这基本上是为了减轻医院本身的压力。当然，曼哈顿的四季酒店，在平时是一个相当昂贵的居住地，现在正向医护人员开放。我的意思是，酒店现在正以多种方式被使用。它们主要被用作隔离中心，因为当然有很多人不得不离开
the countries they may have been working in or living temporarily in or in a holiday. And of course they then have been working in, or living temporarily in, or in a holiday. And of course, they then have to be put into quarantine for a 14-day period. So we've seen hotels open the summer offering, in fact. Quadantine packages, where for 14 days you can go and live in a rather nice four or five-star hotel, and have 14 days of quarantine there. Others are being
他们工作、临时居住或度假的国家。当然，他们必须被隔离14天。所以我们看到酒店在夏天实际上提供了隔离套餐，在那里你可以住进相当不错的四星或五星级酒店，进行14天的隔离。其他人则是
forcibly quarantined by governments. So when they arrive back on home soil, you then have to spend 14 days in self-isolation. Is there something you get in these quarantine packages that is different like all your food kind of brought to your room? Yes, I mean the packages are providing the same service as a hotel normally would. Although, I mean some people I've spoken to have been in various hotels dotted around the world have complained that the level of service is not quite what they would have expected. So obviously the food I'm all for is not what it would be under normal times. So you're stuck in your room,
被政府强制隔离。所以当他们回到家乡时，必须进行14天的自我隔离。这些隔离套餐里有什么特别的东西吗，比如所有的食物都送到房间里？是的，这些套餐提供的服务与酒店通常提供的服务相同。虽然我交谈过的一些住在世界各地不同酒店的人抱怨说，服务水平并不完全如他们所愿。显然，食物并不是正常时期的水平。所以你被困在房间里，
it's a beautiful room maybe, with a nice view, but you can't go anywhere. You have food brought to your door, but as I say, it won't be of the same quality that one would have expected in such a hotel, but that's a relatively nice way of being quarantined. In some cases, for example, I spoke recently to a student from Bosnia who had been working in Germany as a researcher and had to return home to Bosnia-Herzegovina. And when they returned home, they were taken to this one hotel in a place called Tuzla in Bosnia and they were to stay there for 14 days. They were basically forcibly held there for 14 days. And this has been happening all over Europe. You know, those that return, they simply have to submit
也许是一个美丽的房间，视野很好，但你哪儿也去不了。食物送到门口，但正如我所说，质量不会达到人们在这样的酒店所期望的水平，但这是一种相对不错的隔离方式。在某些情况下，例如，我最近采访了一位来自波斯尼亚的学生，他曾在德国担任研究员，不得不回到波斯尼亚和黑塞哥维那。当他们回到家时，他们被带到波斯尼亚一个叫图兹拉的地方的一家酒店，他们必须在那里待上14天。他们基本上被强制关在那里14天。这种情况在整个欧洲都在发生。你知道，那些回来的人，他们只能服从
to be kept in isolation. And what about homelessness specifically? How are you seeing hotels being used? Yes, in the case of the UK, I mean, the crimeaza, I think the holiday in and therefore the holiday in express, have come to an agreement with the UK government and the mayor of London, they've basically handed over hundreds of rooms. I don't know what the financial agreement was there, but those rooms will be available for the homeless of London. And I have to say that the homelessness was becoming something of a crisis in London.
被隔离。那么专门针对无家可归者呢？你看到酒店是如何被使用的？是的，在英国，我认为假日酒店和假日快捷酒店已经与英国政府和伦敦市长达成了协议，他们基本上交出了数百间客房。我不知道那里的财务协议是什么，但这些房间将提供给伦敦的无家可归者。我必须说，无家可归问题在伦敦正成为一种危机。
And it was very noticeable over the last couple of years in particular. So it was a real effort required for the UK government to try and get homeless people off the streets. And of course they were hugely vulnerable in the situations that they were in. But there was a big kind of effort to do that and who hotels were generally used as places to house the homeless. And do you know in those cases like were they moving homeless folks into hotels that were already showing symptoms or was it just a proactive let's get everybody inside so that nobody is as vulnerable to this as they would be outside.
在过去几年里，这一点尤为明显。因此，英国政府确实需要付出巨大的努力来让无家可归者离开街道。当然，他们所处的环境使他们非常脆弱。但确实有很大的努力来做这件事，酒店通常被用作安置无家可归者的地方。你知道在这些情况下，他们是把已经出现症状的无家可归者转移到酒店，还是仅仅是主动把每个人都安置在室内，这样就不会像在外面那样脆弱？
Well some utopian countries have been testing far more than the UK. The UK, the testing hasn't actually the numbers have been quite low and so there was no time and no facility is actually to test people who perhaps were you know demonstrating any kind of symptoms even if minor symptoms or kind of early symptoms it was just that they had to be taken off the streets and given somewhere to live, given a roof over their heads for a short period so that they one wouldn't spread the disease and two might not be exposed to those with it. And I'd be really interested to see what these hotels look like inside
嗯，一些乌托邦国家比英国进行了更多的测试。在英国，测试的数量一直很低，所以没有时间和设施来测试那些可能表现出任何症状的人，即使是轻微症状或早期症状，只是他们必须被带离街道，给他们一个居住的地方，给他们一个遮风挡雨的地方，这样他们既不会传播疾病，也不会接触到携带者。我真的很想看看这些酒店内部是什么样子
at the moment and what kind of services there are and to what extent those people are being looked after. And that I do not know because it's impossible of course to enter into any of these buildings. It's impossible for me to travel really, I can't even go to my university, let alone to one of these hotels for the purposes of research. And what about just sort of like this scale overall around the world? Like do you feel like the number of hotels that have transformed into kind of responding to this crisis in some way would be more than we've maybe seen since one of the world wars.
目前的情况，以及有什么样的服务，这些人得到了多大程度的照顾。我不知道，因为当然不可能进入这些建筑。我真的无法旅行，我甚至不能去我的大学，更不用说为了研究目的去这些酒店了。那么全球范围内的规模呢？你是否觉得转型应对这场危机的酒店数量比我们在世界大战期间看到的还要多？
I think we've never seen anything like this since the Second World War. You've had individual crises in individual countries or even regional conflicts, but you've never seen anything like this because what's happened here is that the hotel industry has been to seriously damage by this. It will take a long, long time for hotels to recover, for tourism to recover from this. So if you even think optimistically that we might get back to some kind of normality in terms of tourism by 2021. So there will be a two to season in 2021. You're looking at at least a year's income, really lost by hotels.
我认为自第二次世界大战以来，我们从未见过这样的情况。你经历过个别国家的个别危机，甚至是区域性冲突，但你从未见过这样的情况，因为这里发生的事情是酒店业受到了严重的损害。酒店业和旅游业要从这次危机中恢复需要很长很长的时间。所以，即使你乐观地认为我们可能会在2021年恢复某种程度的旅游常态，那么2021年也会有一个旅游淡季。你看到的是酒店至少损失了一年的收入。
So of course they have to adapt and they have to become something else and they have to offer their services because otherwise they may simply go out of business. And I think that perhaps those hotel chains that have offered their services at this particular time might be more favourably, it loops upon, than those that didn't, if they need to be bailed out in the future. Because of course, the COVID-19 crisis may end in intensity, the kind of intensity that we're experiencing at the moment, but it will take a long time for life to go back to normal for people to feel that they want to travel again for borders to open. you know, you have weddings and parties and business meetings and holidays and so forth. That can't happen. In the countries that are really hit by COVID-19, those hotels have no other option really than to kind of redeploy and repurpose
所以当然他们必须适应，必须变成其他东西，必须提供他们的服务，否则他们可能会直接倒闭。我认为，那些在这个特定时期提供服务的酒店连锁店，如果未来需要救助，可能会比那些没有提供服务的酒店受到更友好的对待。因为当然，新冠疫情危机可能会在强度上结束，即我们目前正在经历的那种强度，但生活恢复正常、人们感到想再次旅行、边境开放需要很长时间。你知道，你有婚礼、派对、商务会议和假期等等。这些都无法发生。在受新冠疫情严重影响的国家，这些酒店除了转型和重新利用之外，真的别无选择
and become used as something else. something else. 99% of Israel was produced this week by Katie Mingle and Abby Medon, with help from Emmet Fitzgerald. Mixing tech production by Srivusif, music by Sean Riel. Kurt Colsted is the digital director, the rest of the team. Is Delaney Hall, Joe Rosenberg, Vivian Leigh, Chris Baroube, Avery Truffleman, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, which is scattered about in various East Bay apartments but is centered in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. We are a proud member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most
并被用作其他用途。本周的99%的以色列节目由凯蒂·明格尔和艾比·梅登制作，埃米特·菲茨杰拉德提供了帮助。混音技术制作由斯里武西夫负责，音乐由肖恩·里尔创作。库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监，团队的其他成员包括德莱尼·霍尔、乔·罗森伯格、薇薇安·李、克里斯·巴鲁贝、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼、索菲亚·克拉茨克和我罗曼·马斯。我们是旧金山91.7K ALW的一个项目，在广播街制作，该街散布在东湾的各个公寓中，但中心位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。我们是PRX旗下Radio Topia的骄傲成员，这是一个由最
innovative podcasts in the world. Fun mall at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet to me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram and Reddit too. We have links to all the organizations that Katie talked to and ways to get involved at 9i9pi.org. Radio tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
世界上最具创新性的播客组成的独立集体。详情请访问radiotopia.fm。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIorg。我们也在Instagram和Reddit上。我们在9i9pi.org上有凯蒂采访过的所有组织的链接以及参与方式。Radio Topia，来自PRX。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。